you were at a Dodgers game I think you
went to two in a row and you sat in a
very prominent seat and you know some
celebrities have the Hat and they keep
there they keep the low profile smart
ones the smart well I don't know but you
apparently everyone could see you
because where were you sitting you were
like near home play
I was right behind home plate but
there's like you know okay so they're my
friends seats I do not have amazing
seats at the Dodger game but I would
love to yeah me too and so but like and
they won by the way that night that was
like not a lot of people in the seats
next to us and so it was like just I
really stood out okay right so I wasn't
even realizing that because I was so
having so much fun I was so happy to be
there and I was like really animated
like I am and talking to my friend
talking to my husband and and then we
started getting texts from people going
oh my god we see you at the game nice
seats we totally see you every time
someone's up to bat and so then my dark
mode kicked in ex I was getting some
shade from people on Twitter who are
like oh god why just sit down chill out
cuz what happened is my celebrity hi
like well that's never on very well in
any way but I turned into a momma cuz I
went oh my god and I made the kids my
boys are at home and I made them start
watching so I could like wave to them
and like you know and so I'm like okay
it's pretty funny though you saying like
kids I'm on TV I know you think I was
thinking the same thing yeah you're a
celebrity who's always on said you're
like what
where's the camera the context of a
baseball game you know and my kids are
super into Little League I'm obsessed
with Little League I'm now obsessed with
baseball and so I'm like doing little
dances and then some people were putting
on Twitter like the little video and it
looks so obnoxious right I look like I'm
trying to be oh look at me I was holding
up the cracker jacks you know and like
doing the whole thing all for my kids
right oh I'm sorry I was annoying I get
it
right it's not trying to be annoying I
was just trying to like interest my kids
at home and make them think you did wait
a minute you say that now but I know I
swear I'm gonna be you get treat you did
three ads for sprite also while you were
there
let me such a great way to get a free
endure it wouldn't work that way I would
try and get I would try and sit in a
ball park where I could be seen and then
I do you know little commercials report
yes yeah I'm gonna call em yeah and then
write them and say where's my money I
want my money ten minutes on your new
sausage yeah no we're we're but then I
threw the first pitch the next day you
threw the first pitch I got that and I
threw from them and I'm gonna brag cuz
I'm not a sports girl so I feel like I'm
allowed to brag is that okay yeah okay
dude I threw first pitch from the mound
and threw a strike that's amazing you
know my kids play Little League and I
felt like I needed I brought them on the
field with me I felt like I really
needed to like kick butt for them yeah I
did it was awesome I gotta brag I threw
out a first pitch once and I did for the
for the Red Sox and I did so well that
they kept me in for six innings I'm sure
there's one person here who believes
that after the game that Kershaw threw
the other day people who are also
tweeting to me like hey you should go I
guess none of you watch that game yeah
okay they come here from all over not in
the United States but all over the world
to see this show right any of our
audience tonight is from Sweden so oh
yeah I just made that up no idea if
that's true they're assembling furniture
up there in the audience
you